ja aber dann musst du auch lol ich habe
gerade irgendwie ALT gedrückt so dass
ich kurz aus Minecraft draußen warte ich
die ganze Zeit rum guck mal ich drücke
gerade gar nichts ich kann hier
klatschen
und ich hüpfe weiter
hallöchen meine lieben Freunde und
willkommen zurück bei einer neuen Folge
t3c wir waren hier stehen geblieben bei
diesem wasserparcours und müssen das
schaffen
unseren Videos das gibt es nicht
so viele Insider auch Insider die ihr
gar nicht kennt oh hier noch mit
Strömung drin verarschen
ja sehr sehr viele Insider
sehr sehr ich musste mein Ipod ins
Ladegerät stecken das geht so nicht
weiter das bedeutet eigentlich übersetzt
heißt das in
Sitzer oder
nein das ist äh das nur du Bescheid
weißt was los ist ja ich weiß was ist
ein Insider ist aber ich meine Seite was
heißt das übersetzt wenn du eine Gruppe
hast und du bist ein inside das heißt du
bist innen drin wenn du ein Outsider
bist du wahrscheinlich ausserhalb dieser
Gruppe die versteht worum es geht achso
ja ich habe schon verstanden
jetzt bin ich übrigens auch mal endlich
in der Strömung hier drin sonst bin ich
hier
und jetzt hier auch an der Strömung
und hier auch wieder drin oh Gott jetzt
geht jetzt gerade relativ schnell so und
das ist ja auch wieder drin und hier
auch boah Alter was geht gerade ab hier
was geht da alles ab unglaublich das
muss mir glatt mal angucken weil ich das
sonst nicht glauben würde kannst ja
theoretisch von unten angucken
nicht gerade am aufnehmen jetzt will ich
das gar nicht glauben hier
vielleicht ist es auch gerade einfach
das kann ja natürlich auch sein ja das
ist nicht sonderlich einfach gerade aber
ich bin schon fast am Ende glaube ich
so komm jetzt noch ein kleines Stückchen
ein klitze kleine Stückchen
komm du schaffst das Minecraft Avatar
Alter aber das ist echt das ist extrem
lang der kann nicht der kann doch nicht
glauben dass er das alles in einem Stück
schaffen weißt du guck dir das mal kurz
Ansbach ja ja da bin ich gerade schon
lang hier bin ich überall lang Moment
dann bin ich hier lang und hier um die
Ecke und hier bin ich dann
runtergefallen genau hier
okay aber da muss doch ewig weiter noch
du musst ewig weiter hier nach vorne
nach oben nee das kannst vergessen doch
genau das gleich wieder ein Block nach
rechts ein Block nach oben und dann erst
Wasser das geht nicht die ganze Zeit
schon hingekriegt
vielleicht ist es einfach mit der guck
mal oder geh mal den geh mal die Strecke
allgemein noch weiter wie weit das hier
noch geht das geht hier noch überall her
hier um die Ecken noch ein kleines
Labyrinth hier ist dann einfach nur
schwimmen hier geht's dann wieder normal
weiter
das kriegst du noch hin das ist mir das
mal überspringen wir haben schon lange
nichts mehr übersprungen äh ja ja bin
ich bin ich dafür
oh mein Gott
ohne Scheiß das Ding in einem Run
durchmachen dass welchen Videoantwort
wert aber setzt euch nicht so unbedingt
zehn Stunden dran zu posten habt hört
einfach auf zu meckern was da meckert
also würde ich auch nicht sagen
es ist wieder so befehlend ja bleibt
einfach ruhig es geht ja um den
Unterhaltungswert und da möchten wir
nicht dass wir 1000 mal fehlen und jetzt
noch 20 Kommunikation
es geht eigentlich geht's nicht so
ist aber so ihr wisst was war mein was
man meinen Sohn wir sind keine übelsten
Gangster die denken alles wie ein
Assistent nein natürlich haften vieles
beste
wissen genau
ja ja ich kannte schon den Dubstep
Dingens Damen als das war ziemlich geil
crystallizer heißt das Lied oh mega ich
nenne Dubstep Remix im Eis okay und hier
ist doch genau das gleich wieder eins
nach vorne eins nach oben siehst du das
hier eins nach vorne das Problem ist
noch ein bisschen ich möchte nicht dass
das letzte Level hier so zu Ende geht
ich glaube ich gucke erstmal wie lange
das ganze ist geht hier entlang da geht
sie um die Ecke und runterfallen es gibt
noch mal hier entlang
natürlich länger als letzte Manager nach
vorne nach oben ums Eck und so eine
Spirale
lol
Alter guck mal
wie groß dieser Gang ist schon das kann
doch nicht sein irgendwie
jetzt kannst du auch gleich knicken
sollen wir einfach diese Challenge quasi
beenden und mal versuchen bei Level 17
das letzte zu machen kurz so als
Ausgleich sage ich mal ach so dass wir
17 Nummer anfangen oder was das für 17
ach so ja das wie die komplette 16 nicht
werden sondern dass wir die 17 Anfang
die als letzte auch wenn es schon von
der nächsten Zone ist also Zone C ist
doch noch mal die erste Challenge
durchmachen bei Zone 17 quasi nur die
ersten drei machen als Ausgleich dafür
dass wir bei 16 nicht das letzte gemacht
haben wenn guck mal wie die nächste
Challenge ist wenn sie besser ist als
die dann dann könnten wir mal ja das das
wäre vielleicht besser ohne Witz ihr
habt es gesehen ich kriege oder ich oder
wie kriegen das so nicht dann einfach
hin wir sind nicht so die die
Wasserexperten dann wir sind nicht so
die Wasser nein wir sind nicht so die
Wasser
ja
sich geflogen aber schon alles ja das
ist jetzt die neuen das war schon
Gesicht
laufen ja ich komme mit ja ich komme
das beste anschauen
okay wo ist denn jetzt dieses
Hauptgebäude
Challenge 17 ist hier Spark jo es war
kein Creeper der hat aber eine Spinne
explodiert erledigt hier ist 17
ja die ersten drei machen wir gucken mal
wie sich so entwickelt wenn es gut ist
kann man theoretisch auch noch länger
machen
schnell schaffen
ja oh Gott da muss man ja ein bisschen
schneller sein
hab gefragt
nein Alter
in
4,9 Sekunden
ich hoffe
zu springen ohne
uns und die Tür zu aktivieren nämlich um
Verweis durch lang springen muss und
dann kriege ich das hin denke ich mal
okay
oder du drückst mal kurz den Schalter
und dann kann ich ja schon mal
durchgehen ah nein
fast
okay
oh ich dachte du gehst als durch aber
ich darf nicht
in den Schalter und dann läufst du
wieder zwischen an dem muss man selber
drücken so Druck
nein
ich probiere mal ich gehe mal hier ganz
zum Rand
ach mann wenn man so ach ich konnte
nicht mehr sprinten das war das Problem
auf
habe es auch geschafft gut
das ist übrigens gerade 17.3 ja ich habe
aber kein Ding okay ich wollte nur
wissen muss
oh Mann ich dachte du merkst es nicht
schade
zwar können wir ja verarschen
hab's knapp warte nochmal da geht die
Tür noch mal auf habe noch mal drauf
gedrückt
nein ach ich muss noch einen höher gehen
ach so das vergessen
sechs Minuten schaffe ich wieder alles
hast du gesehen
so
dass der Weg auf jeden Fall lang ich
mach mal zuerst gut machen
einfach kannst du ich habe versucht ohne
sprinten das zu machen
ging alles allerdings nicht so gut
aha das war doch okay dann relative
Zeitspanne oh Gott ich war noch mal ich
war normal ich war normal ja machen wir
mal
nein ach Mann ich war relativ schnell
aber
kurz das Textstück
vielleicht ruckelt ist dann das ruckelt
allgemein nicht aber vielleicht ein
wenig weniger
ein wenig weniger
ach nein
und noch mal
so knapp
nein ach auch knapp guck mal jetzt geht
die Tür ist offen gleich warte Moment
jetzt ist es offen gegangen das hätte
ich locker geschafft wenn ich nicht
runtergefallen wäre
nein ich habe vergessen sprinten zu
drücken sonst hätte ich geschafft guck
mal die Tür geht jetzt erst offen ach
mann das regt mich so auf dass ich dann
immer runterfalle ich bin quasi zu
schnell aber auch zu unvorsichtig und
schon wieder runtergefallen übrigens ist
der komplette Kreislauf gerade an
irgendwie
Kurzschluss drin sein aber das ist doch
gar kein Kurzschluss drin wir haben Sie
darauf offen kann ich gar nicht
nachvollziehen gerade ich verstehe nur
Bahnhof von einem Redstone
ich kann nur einfach das einzige was ich
kann ist einfach nur scheiße labern
Moment
egal sie sich meine Aufgabe Schaltung zu
gucken also ist ein Kreislauf aktiv
mit sich selbst irgendwie verbindet
das heißt vielleicht hat man einfach
ganz schnell Dingens gedrückt
miteinander reden
okay ist auf jeden Fall dauert ein
bisschen
ja klar
ich drück mal ne
ja aber dann musst du auch lol ich habe
gerade irgendwie ALT gedrückt so dass
ich kurz aus Minecraft raus warte ich
die ganze Zeit rum guck mal ich drücke
gerade gar nichts ich kann hier
klatschen
und ich hüpfe weiter
sehr gut
ich bin ein Affe ich kann klatschen und
alles mögliche gleichzeitig nee dich
ach so übrigens guckt
bin gerade relativ schnell unterwegs
nein das war jetzt meine Tür die offen
gegangen wäre
Spark
hallo Spark bist noch da
okay da scheint jetzt gerade Skype
abgekackt zu sein ich würde einfach mal
sagen wir sehen uns im nächsten Part bei
Spark ist natürlich jetzt blöd dass das
einfach so zu Ende geht ich versuche das
noch mal ganz ganz schnell hierhin zu
schaffen
oh nee doch nicht und warte sparklet the
game das heißt es liegt an Sparks
Internetverbindung ich würde sagen
nächster Part best back haut rein
schönen Tag euch äh trinkt nicht so viel
und die Spinnen oh Gott tschüss